ciao mariners benvenuti in un nuovissimo
vi è una torta o non è una torta
questa sarà la domanda principale di
questo video vi sarà sicuramente
capitato di vedere sui social dei video
di oggetti che vengono tagliati e nuove
nel momento in cui vengono tagliati si
capisce che è una torta e quindi effetto
sorpresa a livello 10.000 del video di
oggi andrà proprio a vedere alcuni di
questi video e fino alla fine non
sapremo se si tratta di una torta o di
un oggetto e quindi noi io insieme a voi
dovremo in quei secondi brevi secondi
della durata del video capire se è una
torta o meno ma bando alle ciance
partiamo subito
ok questa è la scatola di una
torta in scatola c'è scritto cheese cake
sopra c'è anche la marca scritta in alto
credo che sia vera voi che dite
vediamo coltello in arrivo e niente una
porta cioè capite fatta benissimo
ok qui abbiamo un hamburger e e fax è
una torta è fatta molto bene sono
indecisa potrebbe essere vero il panem
m'inganna un po potrebbe essere vero
coltello è un hamburger
rubinato questa è una torta
ap due mete in atto che la torta di
compleanno scusate c'è ha ricoperto il
computer con della panna per far finta e
possono torta ma il computer che fine ha
fatto
e vivo confezione familiare di uova 12
uova
beh mi sembra uova non credo che sia
anche perché come fa essere una torta
vediamo ok no aspettate devo rivedere a
ok quindi io pensavo ok quindi è un atto
è una torta
quindi è commestibile anche il guscio
dell'uovo l'avranno fatto magari con
della pasta da zucchero questo è un
telefono fa il riflesso pure del vetro
un telefono per forza ok il coltello lo
tira via perché sto insomma si rovina il
telefono è un telefono torta o spugna
per i piatti io credo sia una spugna
no vabbè una torta a nora gama che ma
che impressione pongo non immaginatevi
c'è una torta che ha le sembianze della
spugna
cioè mi sentirei come in gola la
sensazione della spugna no questa è una
scarpa
noda non ci credo ma non è possibile
rare cioè perfetta auricolare è un
auricolare stare un po in sé anche per
farlo torda volevo regolare ma in che
senso
c'erano del cioccolato dentro auricolare
non l'ho capita questa se l'avete capita
spiegatemelo voi questa era patata cioè
una patata dai a fare una torta a forma
di pace come fanno a ricreare la buccia
messa scioccata
questa è una melanzana non ditemi che a
torto vi prego poi dominante una
melanzana da cra troppo perfette è una
ciabatta in gomma mi sembra ovvio ce lo
vedete anche voi no e invece una torta
avete visto cioè capite che usciamo
tutti pazzi così questo è un rotolo di
carta igienica si vede cioè nel senso si
vedono anche come dire la ripresa e da
sopra quindi credo che sia molto
difficile ricreare una roba del genere
con una torta ma mai dire mai
infatti è una torta
questa è una pianta c'è la terra cioè
c'è il vaso
non mi venite a dire che una torta no
vabbè non ci credo
c'è una torta questa è una mascherina
ebbe una mascherina non è una torta sono
sicura di quello che dico non è una
torta da cella maschi fare una torta una
forma di mascherina sfido chiunque
qui abbiamo un bel dispenser del sapone
per le mani
c'è anche etichetta dietro con la marca
le cose che sono contenute dentro sapone
e invece anche questa volta ci stavamo
sbagliando perché è una torto qui
abbiamo una bella pizza con vari
ingredienti sopra deve essere una pizza
fatta all'estero perché non mi dà
proprio l'impressione di essere una
pizza autentica italiana
però credo sia una pizza c'è anche il
bordeaux bruciacchiati noce
è una torta dai no non ci posso credere
1 fanno ma poiché gusto avrà st torta
pizza si sia proprio visitati dentro il
nostro
questa è una noce di cocco non mi venite
a dire che una torta si vede proprio
cioè e proprio anche i dettagli sono
troppo troppo precisi per essere una
torta io dico che non è una torta
no dai meri io me ne vado basta cioè
maria io esca non può essere una torta
come anno faccia e la mia domanda è come
fanno a fare la crisi c'e il guscio
della noce di cocco dito con la torta
con qualcosa di commestibile c'è sembra
duro da fuori non so come dire qui
abbiamo degli asciugamani dei tappetini
c'è anche un detersivo dietro quindi
sembra tipo il bucato però un po strani
per essere della sheila marie io dico
che questa è una torta non mi frega di
più ho indovinato è una torta robe lì
anche detersivo una torta 9 non ci credo
io pensavo che fossero li lasci la
maglia tordo artistico forse nero e
invece anche il detersivo una torta
facendo pazza queste torte contorte a
volte torte mi hanno decisamente
scioccato non me lo sarei aspettata per
la maggior parte dei casi in fatemi
sapere quante ne avete indovinate e se
anche voi siete rimasti sbalorditi come
me di fronte a tantissime torte mi
raccomando fatemi sapere anche se vi
piace questa tipologia di video sulle
torte cake or fake perché magari
potrebbe esserci una seconda parte
io rimango un bacione norme ci vediamo
al prossimo